here comes david price getting ready for
his first start in the dodgy uniform his
first one since late in 2019 with boston
so price gave up five runs in his first
two games as a dodger this year but he's
given up just one run in six games since
and that includes in his first outing
off of the injured list tuesday night
one one two three on seven pitches
smith at first with the lead off single
price is 2-2 is hit in the ground right
to max muncie who feeds gavin walks a
little
perfectly positioned and now there's two
out
kevin lux is becoming more and more
interesting in watching him play
shortstop and that's his natural
position to begin with they moved him
over to second
in the absence of corey seeger
lux has done a very good job down at
shortstop they face off with meryl kelly
who made his big league debut as a 30
year old in 2019 he's now in his third
year in the majors first three starts a
disaster that era was above eight but
he's been a lot better since including
his longest outing of the season his
last timeout went six and a third
against miami gave up just three runs
and has reached an 11 straight after
going one for four with the double last
night chopper to third could be a tough
play escobar charges throws late oh he
got him he got him bet's done argue
and out number one
nice play by eduardo coming in on that
and what made him be able to get bets
was the quick snap throw with the
release
i mean that was a very quick release and
throw no bobble there
reddick in his arizona debuts had a
minor league contract on april 12th
really hit well to open the season at
triple a reno
left side
lux has a long run in foul territory
make a very nice backhanded play against
the side wall
gavin does a nice job gathering himself
and staying under that ball peralta off
second as price comes home with a 2-2
swung on and this strike three first
strikeout for price
he goes to diamondbacks leave a base
runner one guard and here's albert
pujols right now he's tied with former
dodger eddie murray for 13th of the
all-time hit list
right field
well-hit
albert
has
hit his first home run as a dodger
his
668th career big league home run is his
first as a los angeles dodger
it goes to the opposite field
josh redick went all the way to the wall
jumped as high as he could he wasn't
tall enough
with a home run and the dodgers take a
two nothing lead
here's bulls who homered his first time
up first dodger home run grounded his
shirt should be too out at second and
out easily at first double play ball to
one of the ending girls probably saying
man i wish i'd have gotten that last
time up
but he gets it here and the dodgers
turned away one hit nobody left on base
we'll go to the fifth the dodgers
stadium two-nothing la first walk of the
night by either side and kelly comes to
the play to strike out victim back in
the third call strike three on the
inside corner that ends the inning oh
it's a walk of the man left not been
able to get anything going with the bats
this is the really really really flat
offense right now so
merrill knows this and
you know he knows he's got to keep
putting zeros up got him looking sosugo
takes a call third strike going down the
fifth inning and that is seven
strikeouts for merrell got him swinging
eight strikeouts for merrell he has
really got it going tonight with that
strikeout pitch two up two down there on
the other really swings hits one to
center
ortega is going to catch it
and has it retired one two three
we played five at dodgers stadium two
nothing on the pool's home run back in
the second two outs for escobar eduardo
had a two-run over last night one right
now would tie the spawn game oh he hung
it edwardo drives it deep to right field
there it goes
escobar we are tied at two
as he gets uh the blast off kelly
scoring marty ahead of him wow what a
nice about that turned out to be for
eduardo
he came back with a curveball and just a
nothing curveball over the middle of the
plate
and he kind of shortened his swing a
little bit
and a quick shot right into the right
center field bleachers so back at square
one here in the sixth merrill kelly who
has struck out eight through five and
hasn't walked anybody two-run home run
for pools the dodgers only two runs
once he's singing it two for three's on
he had to turn her down strike three
right down the middle
he must have been looking for something
out over the plate he took a fastball
right down the middle of the plate for
the ninth strike out of the night for
merrell kelly two down and the throw to
first and muncie
is out at first based in the inning
all of a sudden the momentum is on the
side of the sedona red for the d-backs
you know kelly's been the story tonight
for the dynavax six solid innings
allowed only
four hits in the ball game he has
surrendered two runs he's in a 2-2 ball
game as we play in the bottom of the
seventh will smith first step fly ball
to left field well hit on its way and
it's a 3-2 dodger lead
will smith
into manny wood his fifth home run of
the year dodgers three
arizona two he didn't waste any time the
first offering of the ending well the
bougie here for josh reddick who joined
the diamondbacks today from triple a
reno and escobar going to the dugout
here
and they put le castro in the run for
him
one reason the speed and the 01 the
castro off and running the throw and he
is
out at second base oh what a throw by
will smith
getting the speedy le castro to end the
eight
wow
right-hander joaquin soria
who last worked to scoreless sitting
sunday against the nationals had a
couple of strikeouts second and third
two gone and for tournament lately more
often than not they found a way to bring
the insurance home
popped up
in play
smith the first baseman
and young calls him up and makes the
catch right next to him two on the
inning turner over 11 in the series he
pops up one hit two left dodgers have
left three will go to the ninth it's 3-2
los angeles to the ninth inning we go
kenley janssen looking for his third
save in four games in this series
it's very interesting to watch the
development of kenley's velocity
of the mechanics
he's got a new move on the mount and i
don't know if he'll show it to remind
himself of what he's trying to do but
he's definitely trying to get his hips
more into his delivery
trying to get three saves in a four-day
span for the first time since april of
2019.
sure sounds like josh reddick is back
swung on and missed strike three reddick
down on strikes
and it's the first time he's been
cheered all night well here's ahmed to
pinch it for leyba he's struck him
the dodgers sweep the diamondbacks in a
four-game series and they go eight and
one on this homestead